part one of this parametric's question
is you need to find the equation of this
parabola they do say show and it is
worth two marks so therefore don't skimp
on anything you have to make sure you
actually explain what's going on so the
first thing I do is I differentiate okay
I have to differentiate so that I can
find the grater at that point mercifully
it's very easy to fight because I've got
the x-coordinate the derivative is about
as easy as you can get so I've
differentiated I've found the derivative
at that specific point for that value
there it is right so therefore I can go
straight to this line what's this what
am i coining this is point gradient form
right you can see the Y minus y1 and you
can see the air outside of X minus x1
all the pieces are there I've just on
the substitution straight away okay so
I've got the result that was required no
big deal it then says look carefully
using part one write down the equation
of the tangent to the parabola at Q so
when they say write something down or
State and you can see on the right-hand
side it's only worth one mark no working
is required for this right so you can
see here I've just written it down where
did I get this from
well this coordinate T the x coordinate
and this coordinate y T squared they
just go straight into here you see that
so I've just written it down that's all
I have to do it's really just a stepping
stone to get to part through ok so I've
written down the teacher that p and Q
part three says show that these tangents
intersect at this given point over there
okay so to show that two points two
lines rather intersect I'm just going to
solve simultaneously so this is what I
have you can grab picture that if you
like you can see that what I did was I
knew I was going to make X the subject
so I've left two factorized quite a lot
from this slide to the next what did I
do have a look
I could have expand everything out but I
did it why not
what is that a look this thing here it's
something squared take away something
else go this is difference of two
squares right so therefore I can use my
a minus B factorization a minus B a plus
B and it falls out really neatly okay
because of how much the a and the B have
in common so I get to my x-coordinate as
required what am I going to do with this
I'm going to substitute it back in I can
do it too I have a line but obviously
the tangent at P is a simpler equation
so I go for that and I find the
coordinates as required okay all right
so now comes the tricky part the one
where you really have to think describe
the locus of R as T varies stating any
restriction on the Y corner which is
very nice of them they didn't have to
say that they really try to give you a
clue okay so describing the locus of our
the first thing is have a look at the
coordinates of our have a look at it
there it is so you can see this part
tells you here if you were to write down
the parametric equations are you would
say x equals 1/2 and you would also say
y equals t minus t squared
there are your parametric equations
right you've got you actually got you
want so just have a look at the X when x
equals 1/2 what kind of light is that
this is a straight line what kind of
straight line is it it's up and down
because your x-coordinate stays
consistent so it's always a half so the
first thing that I say is that our moves
along the vertical line x equals 1/2 I'm
describing the lockers right but there
is that they give you this clue hey
there's a range restriction on this Y
can't just go anywhere you like why is t
minus t squared well t minus t squared
is this parabola like this do you see
that that's t minus T squared it's just
I've got a t axis instead of an x axis
well that means it's got a maximum here
it doesn't have a bit of it could go
down forever right so I can say the
greatest value the maximum of Y occurs
at its vertex right which you can see is
very simply T equals 1/2 so you can
substitute that in and you can get this
if that's the maximum then Y can be
anywhere from there and
so this is the range of our okay just to
visualize what's going on what are the
things that might help you is to try and
piece together in your mind where P and
Q are going where are they moving okay
so I want you to I can come back to this
if you want a picture of it but I want
you to have a look at this I'm gonna
animate this in a second but as I've
said before you have to be able to
animate up here because that's the
that's the machine you have to use when
you're in the exam so what is going on
here's the way I've thought about it
okay T is your parameter so T can change
up and down right as T gets bigger can
you see that this this x-coordinate here
also gets bigger does that make sense so
as T increases P booze that way its
x-coordinate is getting bigger and
bigger and bigger
yeah but conversely when T is getting
bigger what's happening to Q I'll have a
look at this yeah it's 1 minus T Wow
busy day today
hello you need to go to the library yes
and I came to you before this time last
year and you said yeah that's fine so
this is okay we're going to dismiss to
miss I adore that because yeah she
really yeah okay I'm gonna have to I
can't I can't do this for you now
because I know records so um lunchtimes
it for password so humor me now from
dangerous to try and get you've got a
you got one other thing if you can try
and find so wait were we
oh gosh okay so we know what happens to
this guy as T gets bigger this guy's
going in the opposite direction
yeah because as T gets larger and larger
this gets more and more negative yeah
does that make sense so this guy's go
this way this guy's going that way of
course if I made T smaller instead of
increasing if I decreased what would
happen where would this guy go we're go
to the left what about this one it would
go to the right okay so they're sort of
gonna cross paths okay at some point
they're actually going to intersect
right somewhere in the middle where will
they go where will they intersect at x
equals 1/2 that makes sense doesn't it
because look when T is 1/2
that'll be 1/2 and so will that so
they're on the same spot right now
remember R is a point outside of the
parabola when I say outside I'd be like
here's the inside he's the outside right
it always has to be outside the highest
is going to go is up to here right it
can't it kind of a break through the
parabola because the changes were
intersect inside they would have be
tangents if they did that right so
therefore you can see the reason why Y
has to be less than 1/4 is because it
can come up to here as these tangents
get closer together yeah it rises it
rises but at that point it stops and
then the pain Q as it where they switch
places and you start going back down
again okay so what does that look like
let me show you okay there's P
there's Q so let's get these guys moving
so can you see P and Q swapping places
like that and you can see what R is
doing shuffling up and down that x
equals 1/2 line but of course it can't
ever go further than that by the way you
see how it sort of moves fast down here
and as it approaches here it's so slows
down the reason why it slows down is
because let me pause it do you remember
what the coordinates of this are thing
are that do you remember what the
coordinates of this point are it's now x
equals 1/2 which gives you this and y
equals t minus T squared right now I
don't have a t axis on here so I just
put an x axis on so this is what the
vertical coordinates are doing
can you see as T changes it slows down
up here right just like any normal
parabola does so that's why as it comes
back up it slows down hits a stationary
point and then comes back down okay so
you need to be able to at least get a
rough idea of what's going on what
constraints there are the fact that the
reason why I can't get in here is
because the point of intersection of two
tangents which always has to happen
outside does that make sense